my guest this week is an activist and
author and president and founder of the
Center for industrial progress
Alex Epstein welcome to the show I get a
pin here now I have a feeling that I'm
gonna be in a lot of trouble just for
having this book on the table just for
putting this book that you've written
right in between us people are going to
be angry right off the bat now they're
gonna they're gonna be by the end of
this interview they'll be converts yeah
we're gonna convert people they'll see
the method of thinking just just makes
so much sense yeah all right well I'm
glad that we're starting with that that
little piece of information right there
because first off a lot of people have
recommended that I have you on the show
people that like you and people that
don't like you just because we do
conversation here so I've said before
that my policy on climate change is
basically I'm not a scientist so I have
to sort of believe what the scientists
tell me what the majority of scientists
tell me I mentioned that to you before
in the green room for a second and you
weren't sold on that concept really yeah
that's traction is really bizarre so
let's let's apply that to eugenics so
let's say we're in the early 1900's you
have a lot of public declared scientific
consensus that the gene pool is being
diluted that we need to sterilize people
that there's what I call global dumbing
right because all the dumb people are
sleeping with each other in procreating
and it's this societal catastrophe the
gene pool is going to degrade and so we
need the inferiors to stop procreating
we need to sterilize them or in the case
of Europe we need to do much more
dramatically negative things to them so
you see these scientific consensus and
you say oh well I'm not a scientist I
got a I should obey so what's why
wouldn't you do that or would you uh
well it's very clear to me that we have
dumbed down things significantly cuz I'm
pretty sure we're in a theocracy at this
point but but all right so we didn't
sterilize enough no so no now I'm gonna
get in a lot of trouble for that so no I
I see your point
and and that's what we're gonna do here
so okay so first off the book is called
the moral case for fossil fuel so let's
do a little fossil fuel 101 because I
was watching a couple of your videos on
YouTube and you had a great video where
you're standing in New York City and all
of these I guess green activists are
walking the
rooo and you have a sign and it says I
love fossil fuels and they're just
yelling slogans at you
yeah forgetting who's right or wrong for
a second like they're just yelling
things and I think part of what you were
trying to show them was that they didn't
even know what they were saying really
so I thought if we just define some
terms to start that would be good so
what are fossil fuels yes I think if you
had asked them and I do this in
universities off and I'll do a poll and
I'll say okay who here believes that
fossil fuels are an unnecessary evil
which means we can get rid of them
quickly and we should you know they're
this addiction when you get rid of them
quickly right half the room will raise
their hands and I say okay who believes
that they're a necessary evil that is
their really bad but we're stuck with
them for some amount of time the other
half raise their hand and I say who
believes they're a superior good like we
use them because overall they're the
best for human life and I raise my hand
and if anyone's read my book they raise
their all right at least some of them do
right and then I say okay great I got a
harder question who here can tell me
what fossil fuels are nobody raises to
settle a nobody good and so but it's a
good lesson and people actually take the
lesson despite being a quote idiocracy
and this is at very high level schools
this isn't like a Pocatello attack or
whatever they might even know more but I
remember doing at this at Wellesley and
I think the video is online and and you
can see and and I make the point well
shouldn't isn't a precondition of having
an opinion of whether something is good
or bad isn't a precondition that we know
what it is right so I appreciate the
questions yeah said the way I'll I mean
I can tell you how I like to define well
yeah well I think most people I think
when they think fossil is I pictured
that little cartoon in Jurassic Park
when they're explaining how they got the
the dinosaur DNA but they're showing you
you know dinosaur decomposing sort of
and then suddenly it turn to oil and
then we pull that out like that's I
think what most people in the most
simplistic way it's think it's something
like that but I'm gonna let you up today
a little bit more I think they just
think it's just just filth it's just
like dirt and filth and it's just you
have this dirty thing and just blow it
into smoke and everyone and everything
looks like China and we really need to
stop using it right okay that's pretty
much the visual okay um now tell me oh
really oh I put it this way fossil fuels
are uh and I'll break this down but it's
a high-energy hydrocarbon derived from
ancient life okay so it's a high-energy
hydro
and arrived from ancient life so
hydrocarbon is one of the key concepts
so it's a combination primarily of
hydrogen and carbon atoms and we you can
probably guess this from the whole co2
controversy basically you have different
kinds of these you have natural gas
which has a high ratio of hydrogen to
carbon that's why when you burn it it
emits the least co2 and then coal has
the highest ratio of carbon to hydrogen
that's why it emits the most co2 when
you burn it to burn something is to
oxidize it to combine it with oxygen so
whenever you burn a hydrocarbon you get
h2o and co2 plus whatever else is
attached to the hydrocarbon it turns out
that this chemical structure stores an
enormous enormous amount of energy and
it also and also turns out that the
ancient plant life or ancient life that
this comes from it's different kinds of
life it turns out there was so much of
that that we have almost unfathomable
amounts of this stuff so my best
estimates that I've seen are really
dozens more than we've used in the
entire history of industrial
civilization so what this gives us from
an energy perspective is an extremely
concentrated and plentiful source of
energy that's starting about 300 years
ago we developed the technology to
harness before that it was useless but
once we developed the steam engine
the internal combustion engine oil
refining modern natural gas technology
this became by far the dominant method
of producing energy on the world
alright so let's pause there for a
second so basically this this former
life so its former plant life animal
life it's all the stuff that it like
playing on earth vermilion depends like
coal it has you know coal is more sort
of terrestrial other things are more
underwater but it's and and I mean
technically it doesn't strictly need to
be from life and there are many theories
that some of it at least isn't it
take like Saturn right Saturn's rings
are made of natural gas they're made of
methane so it's something that occurs in
a non-biological form but for many
reasons we think most of it is
biological and that has some
implications for how long it lasts right
over time but but the current the idea
that we're running out of it quickly has
gone out of fashion recently just
because we keep discovering new
technology so the the base amount of the
material underground is staggering and
it might be far more staggering than
with it yeah I guess I never thought of
that
so specifically because I feel like
years ago maybe
ten years ago people were always saying
well we're going to run out of this
we're going to run out of this right but
now it seems like we're finding gas
fields all over the place aren't they
finding crazy new gas fields in the
Mediterranean right now and all over the
Middle East isn't that happening right
let me speak to two things that can
happen one is you can find a stock of
more raw material which is always
happening but the other and often more
consequential is that you can find a way
to use existing raw material that was
previously unusable so the whole shale
energy revolution which people
oversimplify as fracking that's an
example of that that's where you have
this material called shale which had oil
and gas in it but it was locked in too
tightly to get out you have this modern
combination of technologies that
unlocked it and just as an example in
the book Atlas Shrugged which is my
favorite book yeah one of the heroes
Ellis Wyatt discovers a method for
getting oil out of shale and 50 years
later
this actually happened right well we're
gonna get to some objectivism in Iran
but that must have been particularly
that particularly rewarding for you but
that show that just shows how we know
often no of the raw material but we
can't make it a resource until we have
sufficient human ingenuity right now
fracking I want to talk about a little
bit quick and then we'll get back this
so frac whenever someone says fracking
first of I think of Battlestar Galactica
but then I think of mr. burns slant oil
drilling did you ever see that Simpsons
when he does the slant oil drilling -
because he creates an oil refinery over
here and it's slanted so that he can do
things and it ends up going under Bart
school and all that it's the who shot
mr. burns episodes great great episode
they went after oil not just nuclear so
they exactly so they did go yeah oh so
then you couldn't be happy with that at
all you probably really don't like Lisa
Simpson I would say she's probably not I
never did inna the Simpsons came out I
was the exact same age as Bart I'm born
in 1980 and a great man in 89 and he was
9 and I was 9 yeah and since I've
outgrown him but Lisa I never I never
liked even even when I was a liberal
kind of politically as a kid yeah no but
mr. burns had you fill those two words
he was ever likable he was very funny
yeah so you're not for the three-eyed
fish you'd say well that's a whole
destroy that's a whole interesting
distortion which I think reveals that
the modern invoke all the environmental
which I would call the anti-human or
regressive movement is really an equal
opportunity destroyer and attacker of
every practical form of energy because
there's no man-made co2 issue with
nuclear and yet they viciously attack it
which I think just shows that they'll
find a reason to attack any form of
energy that actually works right and we
can discuss okay yeah so let's pause on
that so it's fracking so I feel like
people have no idea what fracking is and
I did obviously some research before I
sat down with you and you know you see
all these videos of people turning on
water water bursts at the flames
generally that's I would think that
that's not so great so sell me on
fracking isn't that kind of like a funny
way of marketing things is that like
there are some cultures of people with
water bursting on planes like an odd
thing water racking into fire is bad I
mean this kind of goes with the issue of
look when you hear climate change you
just sort of ask the scientist what they
think with everything we need to look at
at the full context of the technology
both can very carefully both at its
potential positives and its potential
negatives so even if someone could show
me that fracking is leading to a lot
more people's faucets on water which is
completely bizarre but even if that were
true I would want to know the whole
context of what's the benefit of this so
for example oil and gas are the two
fundamentals or two of three
fundamentals of modern agriculture oil
is the only thing that powers modern
agricultural machinery primarily a form
of diesel so there there's just no fuel
that has that kind of versatility that
kind of portability and natural gas
makes modern fertilizer so billions of
people's lives depend on that so
fracking or more accurately shale energy
technology that's enabling billions of
people to live who would otherwise
starve so in my moral philosophy I take
that into account when I think of
something I don't just look for the
negative so the principle is we need to
look at the full context and often
attackers just look at the negative
context now you do need to look at the
negative part of the context and when
you investigate that I mean well you
just find which anyone who studies water
knows is that the number one contaminant
of water including with methane which is
natural gas is Mother Nature so if you
look at the US Geological Survey
something like twenty percent of just
regular water wells are naturally
contaminated so this is why for
shuri's you have records of people
lighting their water on fire so one
thing that Gasland brought to the fore
is because josh fox was against natural
gas and that that brought a premium to
anyone who could show natural gas in
their water and blame it on fracking but
that doesn't mean that there was
causation now theoretically there could
be but it's very rare and this is very
much a solvable problem if I turn on my
water right now in San Francisco and it
like lights on fire that's not like the
end of the unit it's not even it lights
on fire right it's if I strike right now
do it right wife's on fire right so it's
not that flame is coming out of the
faucet you need the whole thing of the
building burned down or there's nothing
like this so you have to have a very
proactive attitude where you want the
technologies to be as good as possible
and one conspicuous attribute of the
anti humans is they always want the
technologies they're against to be bad
like that you really feel viscerally
that they want a catastrophic climate
change to be true and I asked this
question on Twitter nobody has ever
contradicted me how many catastrophists
do you know who would be happy if they
found out they were wrong because
they're gleeful every storm and every
every bad weather event that they
attribute to co2 and you know SUVs and
that kind of thing there's a real Glee
there as I would and sometimes I'll tell
them like a counter fact like hey you
know that actually the rate of people
dying from climate is going way down
we're actually way safer and they
immediately scream at me I said wait a
second shouldn't you be happy is that
there's a possibly but they're not happy
people in general but they're not
they're not happy about the potential of
progress all right so there's a lot
there so let's let's pause with that so
how did you get involved in this because
I can see how passionate it is for you
and obviously you've staked out a
position that is not politically popular
so like when you go to this rally in New
York City it's not fun being yelled at
people and told you're evil and you're
sick people were saying Yuri city's a
sellout they don't know anything about
you you know doing so how did you even
get involved and interested in this in
the first place well I mean being
politically popular I think is a pretty
poor goal to have yeah I mean I I'm
really so my background was I was like a
total math science kid until I was 14 or
15 years old like no interest in
politics no interest in writing I
thought those people are the biggest
losers like what I do
in terms of primarily being a
philosopher and talking about things
like as a kid I thought there was no
worse thing that you could do with our
life if you were to be good what you had
to do is you had to be an athlete a
businessman or like a scientist slash
engineer I was 14 years old like kind of
the peak of my scientific career I won
the National at Mars rover design
contest and so that was totally my
direction I remember having a
conversation with some friends and they
were arguing liberal and conservative
they said what are you
I said what's a liberal what's a
conservative you know which most people
at 14 know that right and they started
making fun of me and I said you know
what I'm tired of all you idiots like
yelling at each other and nothing I
hated it because it was so illogical and
people were just yelling there was no
common ground I said you know what I'm
gonna think logically about this just
like I do about engineering and sort of
since then I've just been fascinated
with the question of what are the
fundamental things that actually lead
human beings to success what are what I
call now the fundamental principles of
human progress and I went through being
a liberal conservative a libertarian and
as you mentioned discovering iron Rand
when I was 18 we've had a really big
impact on me but I really cared about
that issue and it really bothered me
that people couldn't have intelligent
discussions and there was no common
frame of reference so a lot of my career
really all my career has been a trying
to figure out what leads to progress and
B how to persuade other people so when I
see the anti human movement as I call it
I think that movement contradicts every
fundamental principle of progress I
think it contradicts human flourishing
I forget contradicts individual freedom
I think it contradicts critical thinking
I think it contradicts our naturist
transformers of nature so I really hate
it and I hated it since I was 18 and
I've loved ability and and I only got
into energy like nine years later but I
really oppose the anti human movement so
it's it's about fossil fuels but it's
about every form of making life better
and I think fossil fuels is one of many
things that's really good that the
Greens have misrepresented as poisonous
right so we'll get to the grains in a
second but so I imagine that a certain
amount of people watching this are going
to say all right so he's into fossil
fuels and ease into AI and Rand and
they're going to say well Hine read it
was somehow selfish I mean that's when I
when I've talked to your own Brook how
and I talked to mark Pellegrino and a
few other people that that seems to be
the main critique that it there's a
selfishness
to this and when I had John Fugelsang
who's a bar lefty on you know that's
what he was attacking he had him on the
week after I had your own it was like we
did one and then and then we did the
complete opposite and I think they're
they'll try to link the objectivism idea
to well you're just want to use
everything now while you can and you're
not going to leave anything for anyone
else now I'm pretty sure you're gonna
say that's not the case but I'll leave
it there I'd be surprised if they made
that connection from what I've said so
far so what I've said so far is related
to Iran in terms of thinking about
things in the full context which i think
is a very important principle and
certainly one that I learned a lot about
from her but that that should go toward
this idea of being integrated in our
thinking and long-range about our
thinking so I can't take anything I said
so far as short-range but in terms of
selfish I mean what is selfish mean this
is another issue where we need clarity
so yeah to me selfish means that I act
from my own interest but I think the
proper interpretation and the moral
interpretation of that is that I do that
in harmony with everyone else doing so
but even if I didn't I mean if the
climate is actually just ruining
everyone's life right now that's not
selfish so there's this idea of the
harmony of human interests and that
would apply here so that's why we need
to explore something like co2 because if
co2 is really making the world into an
inferno whether you're an egoist or an
altruist lots of people are going to get
hurt yeah for the record I don't believe
the premise that I live - but I know
that that's all that's one of the
critiques that I hear a lot because I
know that if you if you live in a way
that's for yourself well living a good
life for yourself means not destroying
the environment because you have to live
in the environment it means helping
other people in your community because
you got to live with these other people
I I don't view that as selfish but I
know that that's one of the one of the
critiques that's what I wanted to talk I
don't yeah hope hopefully but we'll see
what happens all right so basically
you're saying that we have this stuff
it's here it is not only good but it has
created more good then then pretty much
anything else that in the last 300 years
we have more public health we have more
ability to do things and transform
societies and the
there's just nothing to compare to that
that yeah I think it's important though
that it's primarily a future looking
perspective so I hear both the opponents
and the supporters of fossil fuels often
talk about this as if this is a this is
an issue in the past where it's just a
history lesson right right
Oh fossil fuel has brought us here
therefore we have to use them and then
the opponents say sometimes I say
epstein oh you're just showing that
fossil fuels were useful in the past but
not useful in the present I think if
people read my book that's not at all
true i it's important to understand the
past history of energy for a couple of
reasons one which I talked about in
Chapter one of the book the secret
history of fossil fuels is that all the
catastrophes predictions made today are
actually very old predictions there are
several decades old they have been
tested they've failed and and so we have
a lot of material for analysis but even
more important in terms of energy if we
look at the relationship between energy
use and every aspect of human life we
see this very dramatic positive
correlation and what that points to is
what is energy so I mentioned and why
it's important so I mentioned you know
fossil fuels as a potential source of
energy this high-energy hydrocarbon but
the fundamental behind that is what is
energy so energy is really our ability
to use machines to improve our lives and
what we see is the more access to that
we have the better we can make
everything and I mean everything
everything everything so I go to a lot
of trouble to show that so yeah you know
from agriculture I mentioned so I
literally say the oil industry solve
world hunger and people think that's a
joke but it's really true because
basically we could farm more and create
more yeah for more people I mean
basically you you know you and I as
human beings we might work out but we're
very weak right we can't we're not
Superman right now if we had Superman we
wouldn't need oil because Superman his
real skill is not rescuing Lois Lane his
real skill is industrialization right I
had a Superman I would just say like you
know get all the ore out of the mines
and like that's his whose superpower is
power the record I just watched that
Batman Superman thing and I don't even
know what his skill is at this point
that thing was such a freaking mess okay
so that's a total slob but I get to
watch it but I hey
is who okay okay I want to get dumb see
you you want to work out an intellectual
level if you need like three hours of
like dumbing your brain that's your I
fly a lots and my usual remedy is to
watch them because I have this
temptation to go to the theater so I
just say wait three months I'll watch
the first five minutes and I'll hate it
and then I'll never I'll never have to
deal with it I would put money on it so
so okay so we have anyway like basically
what I'll allows us to do is to be like
Superman we can multiply or any form of
energy but we can multiply our the
amount of energy the amount of power we
have by hundred times or more and that
enables 1% of us to be farmers instead
of nearly a hundred percent in the past
so it's just this amazing thing but one
other example that just to show you the
breadth of it is medical research
because often I'll say look at look at
these insane correlations between energy
use and life expectancy and they'll say
oh that doesn't leave you with energy
it's just medical research and say well
how did those researchers get time to do
that research because they certainly
don't any time when they're on the farm
so basically the more physical labor we
can do through machines the more time we
can spend doing mental labor including
both of us have mental labor careers
right right so we need to be very we
need to be very appreciative of energy
but so to go back to your question what
I'm saying about fossil fuels is not
merely they were a good source of energy
and we should sort of be grateful and
give them a gold watch or something like
that what I'm saying is if you look at
the ways of generating energy now by the
standard of what's cheap plentiful
reliable and scalable to billions of
people no industry comes close to what
the fossil fuel industry can do and so
in terms of our moral calculations for
what we want to do over the next several
decades that has to be factored into the
big picture along with these potential
negatives that we can talk about
you